hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich ein
super leckeres einfaches und
unkompliziertes chicken curry für euch
wir benötigen eine halbe hähnchenbrust
das in ca 300 gramm brokkoli eine dose
kokosmilch zwei röhren die ich bereits
in kleine stücke geschnitten habe zwei
teelöffel currypulver ein teelöffel
süßes paprikapulver ein teelöffel
kurkuma ein teelöffel pfeffer und ein
gestrichenen teelöffel salz außerdem
einen esslöffel honig 1 esslöffel
speisestärke 150 milliliter wasser und
pflanzenöl als beilage mache ich reiße
dafür brauche ich eine kleine schale
reis das sind ca 250 gramm
die doppelte menge an wasser ein
esslöffel butter und ein teelöffel salz
den reis habe ich jetzt bereits unter
fließendem wasser abgespült damit die
stärke heraus gespielt wird und es gebe
ich in meinen topf 2 esslöffel
pflanzenöl und brate den reiz darin zwei
bis drei minuten an
anschließend gebe ich das wasser dazu
und auch das salz und lasse das einmal
aufkochen
das muss auch nur ein paar sekunden lang
aufkochen und dann schalte ich das ganze
auf stufe 2 von 980 stufe und lasse das
bei geschlossenem deckel 18 bis 20
minuten lang fertig garen
in meine fahne gebe ich jetzt vier
esslöffel pflanzenöl und gibt dann den
brokkoli sowie die möhren dazu und lasse
das ganze circa drei bis vier minuten
anbraten
dann gebe ich ein drittel von unserem
wasser dazu und lasse das ganze weitere
zwei minuten dünsten
das gemüse lege ich jetzt an die seite
und geht noch mal in die pfanne 3 ist
der film pflanzenöl und berate dann das
fleisch darin an
an der stelle gebe ich auch schon mal
salz und pfeffer dazu verrühren das
ganze einmal gut
danach kommt der honig dazu und wenn das
fleisch gar ist kann auch schon die
kokosmilch dazu gegeben werden
jetzt kommen da noch alle gewürze hinein
und dann wird das ganze gut durch
gerührt
jetzt gebe ich noch das gemüse zurück in
die pfanne und lasse das ganze fünf
minuten lang weiter köcheln
zu guter letzt verrühren ich noch die
speisestärke mit dem wasser und gäbe
dass mit soße damit sie noch ein
bisschen seminar wird und fertig ist das
leckere indische hauptgericht in der
zwischenzeit ist mein reis auch schon
fertig gekocht und jetzt kann man noch
die butter hin zu geben denn ihr wisst
ja butter ist geschmacksträger und
anschließend kann das ganze sofort
serviert werden
das gericht gibt es bei mir mindestens
einmal im monat war es jedem sehr gut
schmeckt und einfach super schnell geht
und falls euch das video gefallen hat
freue ich mich natürlich über einen
daumen hoch oder sogar ein abo und ihr
dürft mir auch gerne auf instagram
folgen bis zum nächsten mal auf s
kitchen